ALL WHILE THE DESTRUCTIVE AGENDA
FAILS ON EVERY FRONT.
THE COHOST OF THE TOP HIT SHOW,
THE FIVE.
THE JUDGE IS WITH US ALONG WITH
OUR FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
SO LET'S START FROM THE LEGAL
ASPECT OF THIS.
I WOULD NOT DOUBT.
I CANNOT GIVE SPECIFICS.
BUT I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE ONLY
REASON THAT WALL STREET
COMPANIES REMAIN IS BECAUSE THEY
GET BENEFITS, TAX BENEFITS AND
PEOPLE LIKE WE WOULD NEVER GET,
FOR DISNEY TO HAVE THE SPECIAL
RIGHTS SINCE 1967, IT'S LIKE
OKAY, TIME TO GO.
>> THEY SHOULD BE TREATED
EQUALLY, THE TRUTH IS THAT THIS
IS A PERMIT THAT HAS EXISTED AND
IT CAN BE REVOKED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THEN DISNEY WILL
NOT HAVE ALL OF THOSE RIGHTS
THAT YOU HAVE ARTICULATED.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE HERE.
WHO ARE THEY TO CRITICIZE A LOT
IT WAS VOTED ON BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN FLORIDA AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR, YOU
KNOW, SUPPORTED BY MORE THAN 60%
OF THE DEMOCRATS IN FLORIDA AND
THE MAJORITY OF FLORIDIANS.
WHO IS THE SMALL MAJORITY OF
THESE PEOPLE THAT DECIDE THEY
ARE GOING TO DICTATE.
AND I LOVE THAT THEY DO NOT
BUCKLE DOWN TO THE NONSENSE AND
I LOVE THAT WHAT HE IS SAYING IS
THAT HE IS STANDING AT THE
PODIUM AND SAYING DO NOT MESS
WITH US BECAUSE WE CAN MESS WITH
YOU LEGITIMATE ME.
WE DON'T HAVE TO MAKE UP THE
NARRATIVE.
AND IF ANYBODY TRIES TO TALK TO
MY 5-YEAR-OLD OR MY 6-YEAR-OLD
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY REALLY
WANTED TO BE A BOY OR A GIRL OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND WHAT HAVE
YOU, THE FIRST THING I WOULD DO
IS I WOULD CALL THE POLICE AND
NONE OF THEM SHOULD BE
DISCUSSING THIS WITH OUR KIDS.
AND NOW WE HAVE PARENTS WHO HAVE
THE RIGHT TO PROTECT AND THEY
KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON AND
FINALLY, JOE BIDEN AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION, AS YOU SAID AT
THE BEGINNING OF YOUR OPENING.
HE NOW WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE STAYS ON TOP OF THE FLORIDA
LAW TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
MONITORING IT SO CHILDREN HAVE
RIGHTS THAT ARE NOT BEING
VIOLATED.
AND HE SUPPORTS FUNDING SURGERY
FOR MINOR SERVICE AGENT CHANGES
AND HE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
BOTTOM LINE WHICH IS THIS.
NOBODY SAYS THAT YOU CANNOT SAY
THIS OR NOT, READING THIS BEFORE
THEY OPEN THEIR TRAPS AND SAY
THIS OR THAT.
>> I'M DONE, THAT'S IT, VERY
FUNNY.
SO WE WATCHED ABOUT THIS, THESE
EDUCATION ISSUES IN THE PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT IN SCHOOLS, IT WAS A
VERY KEY ISSUE THAT I BELIEVE
FACTORED IN TO THE PURPLE STATE
LIKE THIS
T
UNREASONABLE TO HAVE PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT AND MAY BE THOSE ARE
ISSUES THAT THEY CAN DEAL WITH
WITH AFTERSCHOOL PROGRAMS, THOSE
THAT ARE UNCOMFORTABLE TALKING
ABOUT THESE KINDS OF ISSUES AND
THEY CAN OFTEN RATHER THAN OPT
OUT?
>> WELL, THAT PARENTS SHOULD
HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR
CHILDREN, BE THERE MORAL
ARBITER, THAT THEY ARE THE
NATURAL AND LEGAL ARBITER, THEY
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A LEGAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
THE LIVES OF THE OTHERS.
OF THEIR FAMILY.
THE REALITY IS THAT YOU ARE
RIGHT.
THESE ARE EXTREMISTS AS WELL AND
THIS IS A SMALL MINORITY OF
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE BEEN PLACE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE LOUDEST
VOICES OF THE ROOM.
THEY ARE BULLYING EVERYONE ELSE.
AND THEY ARE AFRAID, THEY HAVE A
KNEE-JERK REACTION.
AND THEY DON'T THINK ABOUT IT,
NOT JUST VIRGINIA, BUT MY
GOODNESS, SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL
AND THE RECALL OF SCHOOL ON
SERGEI LAVROV SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS WERE EXACTLY THE SAME
REASON.
WOKE POLICY, CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, AND YOUNG AGES WHEN IT
COMES TO HOMOSEXUALITY, SEXUAL
IDENTITY, LITTLE KIDS AND I'VE
SAID IT BEFORE, THERE ARE NO
STREET CHILDREN OR GAY CHILDREN.
THERE ARE JUST CHILDREN.
THEY ARE BEYOND THAT AND THIS IS
ABOUT A HORRIBLE DYNAMIC OF AN
INSULT DESTROYING THE INNOCENCE
OF CHILDHOOD TO VALIDATE
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS WHY EVERY AMERICAN MUST
STAND UP.
>> LET KIDS ENJOY THEIR